when i came on the case kiki camarena
had been kidnapped and tortured by the
drug lords
because he had caused them great losses
in seizing
10 000 tons of marijuana in chihuahua
mexico
at the very beginning i started to think
something's wrong here
in 89 they signed you to go investigate
what really happened with kiki camarena
and those that assigned you was the dea
why was kiki blindfolded and why was he
tape recorded
hector he says you don't know what you
got yourself into we killed
i said what do you mean we you don't see
this cartoon model slowing down for
decades the women were raped there were
three babies left in baby chairs
and they lit fire into the cars and
burnt those babies to death
why were you not afraid of them i had a
reputation of a badass when the cartel
wants to kill somebody they machine got
him down wherever he's at
you're saying the mexican government is
supporting several of these cartels they
have the backing of the government
totally the cia is inundating our inner
cities
with cocaine so who is the person that
actually
killed kiki did you ever get a chance to
meet him face to face
no but i would love to you would love to
meet him i probably gave him one
beating for kiki camarena
look if you've been following vitamin
for a while you know we've had a lot of
different kinds of guests whether it's
mobsters from mob family
sammy a lot of folks from that end we've
had steve murphy and javier pena who the
documentary the series narcos on netflix
and we talk about a lot of different
topics today
my guest is hector bereles who his
recent series on amazon the last
narc as well as a book that just came
out september 15 a memoir by the dea's
most notorious agent book
i want to kind of give them a little bit
of background for you to know who we're
going to be listening to today
uh he was the former supervisor d.a
supervisor and special agent with 30
years extensive experience
in counter-terrorism and narcotics
enforcement he is recognized as one of
the most highest
decorated drug enforcement agent in the
history of the bureau
he received the federal bar association
medal of valor the federal executive
board chairman special award
and is credited for his handling and
solving of the kidnap
torture and murder of undercover d.a
agent enrique
kiki camarena by drug traffickers in
guadalajara mexico in which
hector received the prestigious dea
administrators award having said that
hector thanks
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you for having me sir i i just
want to make sure
you are not currently in guadalajara
right because i want to make sure you're
safe
uh no sir thank god i'm not there yes
okay so we just want to
we want to make sure this interview
starts and finishes
on time and we're able to go through all
the questions so you know
i was following the story of the last
narc and i was seeing what's going on
with amazon
and there almost seemed to be a lot of
controversy behind this book that you
were launching where
there were a lot of organizations that
almost didn't want you to write this
book there were a lot of organizations
that didn't want the last narc
to be on tv they didn't want people to
see it and some of them were government
and there was some
lawsuits going on amazon you know didn't
want people to know about this so can
you kind of give us the
challenges you guys face before getting
the story to be released to the public
well quite frankly the cia of course
will highly opposed to the story that
i'm putting out which is the truth
regarding cambodia's death and of course
the dea is also not very happy with the
fact that
after 30 years their whole
narration their fake story uh basically
has been uh exposed by me because
uh keiki kamarena was basically
uh killed on orders of our own
government
so so okay so so because of that cia the
fact that they
the orders were given by our own
government to keep kill kiki kamarana
you're saying people still till today
don't want that story to be told even
though that was 30 plus years ago
that is totally correct camarena was
ordered kidnapped
to be interrogated because he had
unknowingly stumbled into a cia
nsc covert gun running operation
uh that was supplying weapons secretly
to the nicaraguan
contras got it and so so
you know you know how sometimes like i'm
from iran and there was a movie that
came out about iran
uh called the argo which ben affleck was
in it i don't know if you had a chance
to see it or not
it was a story about what happened in
the revolution in iran
in 79 and they didn't want to tell the
story about how this organization came
out with a fake movie and they were able
to go to iran and get a lot of the
u.s folks that were you know held
hostage over there and he was able to
release them to a fake movie that they
were making
but the story was told 30 30 years later
why is it such a challenge that they
don't want the story to be told because
it's not like it's the current president
or the prior president
what's their biggest fear if we find out
the truth about what happened with kiki
well currently with the fbi being
exposed to be
basically a corrupt agency
the cia doesn't want to be accused of
being the same thing
they don't want it to be exposed to this
day that they were
involved in ordering camarina
picked up interrogated and
subsequently tortured and of course the
dea
who was at that juncture working
in in uh complicity with with the cia
they were working in partnership
they also did not want it exposed that
that became arena basically uh was over
kidnapped and interrogated by the cia
why though why
because this shows complicity on their
part
here the dea is supposed to be fighting
the war on drugs
and the cia is the major cartel bringing
in
like 80 of the cocaine in the 80s so
here we had working for an
administration that was okay
with funding an unauthorized nicaragua
with drug monies the cia notoriously
because they don't work on procrastinate
constitutional law no constitutional
parameters
they're not a law enforcement agency
notoriously they have
basically aligned themselves with
criminal cartels
paramilitary groups from other countries
and
also intelligence stages for other
countries uh to do whatever it takes uh
they say
in preserving the national security of
the united states
so so hector now for some people that
haven't read the book or they haven't
seen the series on
amazon uh is the is the lawsuit still
pending or that's been scored away and
amazon is now fine and secured with the
show continuing to show on amazon i
understand that they've got it squared
away and uh
there's no painting litigation as far as
i know
got it okay and did you know who wasn't
wanting it to go out was it directly to
cia that was trying to prevent that from
happening
well i understand that i don't want to
get into that because
basically there's no evidence that the
cia
was the one that was pressuring or
whatever threatening uh amazon
uh so i can't say that i know for sure
but i suspect it was a cia
i i'm only saying that is because if
that's the case i mean it's best for the
audience to go see it in case god forbid
amazon takes it down
and they won't be able to show it you
know it's it's uh it creates a certain
level of urgency for the audience to see
what's really in that show but but let's
go back and talk a little bit about your
career i mean you have a hall of fame
type of a career you know
and if you were an athlete you'd be in a
hall of fame for what the work you've
done you know they put you on a lot of
different lists
your name is constantly mentioned by a
lot of different people
but why don't you walk us back and you
know
share with us a little bit about some of
the things you worked on as a da
agent and how did the kiki camarena
project
you know come to you who made the phone
call how did that happen how did you get
that assignment
well i was assigned to work in mexico
and i was sent to the hottest most
dangerous
area which was the sinaloa
area back then it was a hotbed of
violence and drug trafficking
and while there i was involved in
the longest shootout in the history of
the dea
i was involved in a shootout that lasted
over
two hours during the shootout we killed
numerous
mexican colombian drug traffickers
and also we had five
very seriously wounded mfjp agents
we were able to fight the aggression for
like i said two hours
i was able to get the wounded out and uh
because of that i was basically brought
back to washington
and issued the u.s attorney general's
award for
heroism that kind of put a spot on me
with the agency
at the time that that happened that the
camarena investigation
had been going on for about four years
they needed somebody that could
aggressively pursue
the perpetrators and somebody that could
basically recruit eyewitnesses so they
brought me out of mexico after that
horrendous gun battle and they put me in
charge of the enrique camarena case
what year was that it was in 1989
that was in 1989 when you were put on
the case so
the the two-hour shootout in sinaloa was
what 84.85
88 88 so you got the award in 88 and
reagan was president at the time
uh yesterday i believe it was yes
so so you're in by the way where are you
from yourself originally
i'm originally from tucson arizona
you're from tucson arizona and your
family where's your family lineage from
well i don't want to put out where my
family is because i still have to
protect them but they're in arizona
but meaning are you also mexican
yourself
well i'm a mexican uh heritage but i was
born in the united states
okay my family has been here since the
1700s
got it okay got it fair enough uh i only
asked to know that
you know if that was a like when i was
in the military i was in the army i
speak five languages they wanted to send
me to
tikrit uh to go to iraq because i spoke
farsi and i spoke all these other
languages and it was a leverage for me
to for them to leverage somebody like me
to go down wondering if the dea
saw you as being the best person to go
out there because you can also
uh connect with the community well that
was one of the reasons i could connect
with the community i knew the culture
i speak spanish like a native mexican i
could travel to
colombia bolivia all over central south
america working undercover
which i did and i could blend easily as
as you stated because
i speak spanish fluently when i was
undercover in colombia
i would identify myself as a mexican
citizen i carried
identifications to credentials of a
mexican
individual and i could easily blend in
and out of those countries
and post as a mexican and of course
while working undercover here in the
united states i spoke spanish or speak
spanish so well
when that whenever the traffickers were
accused me of
possibly being an undercover dea agent
or an arc i would say listen guy
would you help me get some green papers
and maybe i can apply and get a job with
those guys
so they really they really took it to me
and trusted me a lot
i can see that so when you were in
colombia as an undercover what year was
that
well i was there numerous times 82
uh also in the late 70s
i was in and out of columbia i was there
i don't know five or six times so was it
during the era of pablo or no
absolutely during the era of pablo i was
under i never went undercover into pablo
himself
but i did penetrate the ochoa
organization out of medellin
colombia so yeah i i was in and out of
colombia
did you ever do anything with steve
murphy and javier pena or no
no because when i would go into columbia
i would never meet the dea agent station
there
i stayed in hotels i only communicated
with the agents there
via telephone i was i was ordered never
to go to the embassy
uh so that my uh in case i was being
followed my undercover
situation wouldn't be uh blown so no i
never met him even though i was in and
out
of colombia when they were there got it
so so 88 you're on that two-hour
shootout one of the longest ever if not
the longest ever
you get an award for it you come back in
89 they sign you
to go investigate what really happened
with kiki camarena
who assigned you and what is the
assignment meaning are they saying hey
hector we want you to find out what
really happened to kiki and those that
assigned you was the dea
so how was that process of you getting
that assignment it was a lot of
frustration i think
because they had a specialized team that
came out of new york
that were assigned uh here to los
angeles
uh to investigate the camarina murder
case these folks did not speak spanish
for the most part uh they were used to
working the italian mob
they were an elite group but they did
not
understand the culture of the uh
of mexico they didn't understand
the corruption and how deep it went as a
matter of fact
one time they brought me in from mexico
to ask me about the corruption
this is the lienda team that was
investigating the case before me
and they asked me about the traffickers
having
basically carrying federal agent
credentials and badges
and i said no they just don't carry the
credentials in the badges
they hold the positions and they go what
are you talking about what i'm talking
about is that
they not only carry the credentials in
the badges they actually are assigned 30
federal agents under their command and i
went on to give them an example it would
be like
john gotti being issued fbi credentials
but not just the credentials
he would also be a supervisor in the fbi
and would they would assign fbi agents
under the under goddess command
they said wow is it that bad hector and
i said yes
it is that bad in mexico these
these cartoon members actually hold
government positions in
all aspects of law enforcement and
mexico
and and that's because of the corruption
back then in the government or is that
that's because
you know that was the model or because
corruption they're being bought out
it was uh corruption that had basically
been
you know they took control of everything
because of corruption and
it wasn't just back then
it continues to be even that situation
continues to exist today
and it's even worse today it's even
worse today than the 80s
mexico in the 80s and the 80s it was
yeah i was that corrupt
but it's worse today and it works today
interesting so so you get the assignment
and when you get the assignment
throughout the process i'm assuming you
kind of knew what was going on with kiki
were you yourself curious where you
really wanted to take the job and go and
investigate more for yourself
uh yes one of the main reasons too that
i was placed in charge of the
investigation
is because i had been a homicide
detective
before i came into the dea so they knew
that i had hamas had experience
when i came on the into the case i was
told that
camarena had been kidnapped
and tortured by the drug lords because
he had
caused them great losses in seizing 10
000 tons of marijuana at the buffalo um
ranch growing area in chihuahua mexico
that's
what i was told and believed until i
started looking into the case and i
called the agent that had been in charge
of the
mufalo chihuahua seizures and asked him
what kiki's involvement was
and he told me to my surprise he said
hector
kikica morena had nothing to do with uh
with the seizure of the ten thousand
tons of marijuana at buffalo
i said are you sure i am being told here
that that was a main motive
and he said hector that's a false
narrative they're not telling you the
truth
kiki did not participate in the raids i
know
i i ran the race so at the very
beginning i started to think something's
wrong here
something doesn't smell right then
i am able to recruit believe it or not
a cia operative working in mexico
i had witnesses that were telling me
that there was this white guy
anglo that was working within the
mexican directorate of federal security
that dfs they called him
his nickname was torre blanca because it
means white tower
and they called it white tower because
he was a very tall
anglo guy that was almost six
seven feet tall and i wonder
what is this guy doing working with the
dfs in mexico
that that's incredible i knew that the
dfs had had something to do with kiki's
kidnapping
so i reached out to this guy he had to
have known
what was going on during the time that
camodena was picked up
i called them and i told them i said
listen uh i i i'm in charge of the
company in the case
and i know you're working with the dfs
and as you and i know the dfs was
involved in the kidnapping
camarena and i need you to come talk to
me
and he said i'm not going to talk to you
you said hector you don't even know what
you're involved in
he said leave me alone and i said listen
if you don't cooperate with me i want to
kidnap your white ass
and i'll bring you up here and you know
that i'm serious you know you know that
i'll do it because i've already
kidnapped one guy out of mexico
referring to dr michene and i said i'll
kidnap your white ass
so he said okay okay he said i'll meet
with you
he said you know i can't go down there
because by then i had a warrant for my
arrest for kidnapping dr machine
who had injected drugs into camarena so
he said okay
he said what what are we going to do i
said i want to send some of my agents
to meet with guadalajara and i want you
to talk to them
but i really need you to come to the
united states
and talk to me so basically
i sent four agents down there they set
up a meeting at a hotel room in
guadalajara
an agent from mexico city by the name of
dale simpson shows up
and he says he um he's been he's been
told to participate in the interview
my agent called me and said hey
something strange has happened he said
another agent from mexico city just
arrived
by the name of dill stinson who said
he's been ordered to partake in the
interview with harrison i said i don't
have a problem go ahead and let him
participate well here uh this this this
this d.a agent named dale stinson
requested to speak with larry harrison
alone
with a without basically uh away from
the uh
but uh from being dropped by by my
agents
he met with larry in uh in a hotel room
alone three minutes later
harrison larry harrison the cia guy
comes out and says
hey listen i want nothing to do with you
guys i don't want to cooperate
and left upset my agents then as dale
stinson
what happened uh he said well i don't
know i guess the guy he's got cold feet
he doesn't want to cooperate after all
and that was it they came back
empty-handed
it took me a year to find this guy again
because he went and hit
i finally found him hiding in the oaxaca
mountains of mexico
i got him on the phone again and i said
larry you need to come talk to me
there's no place you can run or hide you
see i will always find you
you better come over here and cooperate
with me he said okay
i'll agree to meet with you but only in
the united states
and nobody must know that i'm coming
he we flew him to los angeles i met with
him
and during my initial interview he told
me he said hector
he says you don't know what you've
gotten yourself into
we killed ikigamarena i said what do you
mean
we he says we both work for the same
government
i'm a cia operative he said
and camarena was
ordered kidnapped and to be interrogated
by my agency the cia and nsc
i almost fell out of my chair i said
what are you telling me he says yes
he says we use the cartels uh to assist
us in in picking
and kidnapping him and interrogating him
i did not participate myself
but he said my handle did
and i was i was i was shocked
i gathered there was something very
sinister
from the very beginning of the
investigation because i had worked in
mexico
and the drug dealers they don't take
time to
kidnap a guy blindfold them interrogate
him uh
make copies of the interrogation when
the cartel wants to kill somebody
vape machine gun him down wherever he's
at they'll walk into an office
shoot somebody in an office kill
somebody in his car
kill somebody in front of somebody in
his house but this
was a very sinister very
very very very very uh strange
investigation
why was kiki blindfolded
and why was he tape recorded
and harrison gave me the answer because
they wanted to know
what he knew what had happened as i said
it before
camarena unknowingly
okay i found out that tons of cocaine
were being flown into carlo quintero's
ranch in veracruz
so he started an investigation into that
what camarena did not know was that that
ranch was being used by the nsc and the
cia
to train contras and they were using
that
as a transshipment location to
ship weapons from there directly to
ilipango
uh where they were later issued to the
contra freedom fighters
to contact freedom fighters okay let me
go back to one thing you were telling
the story about you
said if if you don't tell me larry i'm
gonna come and kidnap your ass because
you know i have a reputation of doing
that
so this is 30 something years ago 81 say
31 years ago 30 years ago
what kind of a reputation did you have
yourself were you somebody they feared
were you who were you with your
reputation he had built in a marketplace
in your world in my world uh
i was chasing the big elephants the big
cartel guys in mexico
i got in numerous shootouts with him the
shootout at the
two-hour shootout that we refer to
earlier that was just one of the
shootouts that i had
been involved in in mexico they knew
that i was hands-on down there chasing
them
i had a reputation of a badass i mean
they they knew that
i was i i i would go i would go to the
tour with them
they knew that i was not afraid of them
that i was constantly
chasing them why were you not afraid of
them
i was afraid of them but i had a job to
do
and i actually i guess i was an
adrenaline junkie i
i i like to be in in dangerous
situations you know like
like these fighter pilots i mean you get
the adrenaline going and you kind of get
addicted to it and i guess i was an
adrenaline addict i don't know
makes sense i i mean it's it's a very
common thing with folks in your world
that they
they get addicted to it once they get in
you realize very quickly if it's
something for you or not or if you get
addicted you're in you may not be able
to stop doing it
and it's tough to step away from it so
so later on you're doing this you talk
to larry he says
we you said what do you mean we we as in
we're all on it together
why do they blindfold him because he had
some information so as you're going
about telling your story
what happens next well larry explains to
me that the reason they blindfolded him
was because
the people that
wanted him interrogated basically were
more americans and there was going to be
ameri at least one american that was
going to be
interrogating kiki the plan was not to
kill him the plan was to kidnap him
bring him to a place interrogate him
waterboard him
not physically you know kick him beat
him which they did
he was supposed to be water uh boarded
by a
waterboarding expert their own guy
a cia operative was supposed to do the
interrogating camarena and the
waterboarding
and i later identified who this cia
operative
was so you later identified who the cia
operative was this the person you're
talking to or the person that was
supposed to waterboard him
no the person that was supposed to
waterboard him another
major cia operative a well-known cia
operative
the cia operative that kidnapped or
basically tracked down
che guevara in south america in bolivia
and killed him and
cut his hands off the same ca operative
that was
involved in putting a bomb on a plane
that was leaving venezuela with the
cuban fencing team blew up in the air
the same cuban that had been assigned
uh to run operations in vietnam uh
operations uh interrogating uh vietcong
he was a major supervisor in operation
phoenix in vietnam
a very well well-known uh c operative
and a very personal friend of president
president george w bush
is this a name you can't you've really
revealed in the book or no
is his name revealed in the book yes it
is what's his name
ismail felix rodriguez
aka max gomez it took me a long time to
identify this guy
my true name because the witnesses knew
him only as
max gomez did you ever get a chance to
meet him face to face
no but i would love to
you would love to meet him yes
let's just say you did what would you do
to him
well if i would have made him when i was
a dea i would have put him in handcuffs
and if i was to meet him now i probably
gave him one
i'm beating for kekica marena
did you have a relationship with kiki
yes i did
how was he as an individual i mean i've
interviewed others that knew him
personally as well
from that era but how was you how was
your experience with kiki
well he he wasn't a personal friend of
mine but he had a bad reputation too i
mean a
reputation of being a badass like i did
he was a no sense
no sense guy he was a very serious guy
he had a very strong penetrating look
about him
he uh he was uh a pretty tough character
and a great agent great agent what what
makes a great agent in your world
in my world a great agent is
an undercover agent a guy that goes
after them a guy that mixes it up with
him
a guy that is not a disc choppy uh uh
a guy that uh you know doesn't want to
run around in a soft white shirt with a
tie
and uh uh you know wearing the old spice
cologne and the
college uh graduation ring uh he was he
was like me he was a
he was a gunslinger like i was and i
respected him
for that got it so so so afterwards once
you found that out
were you uh were you being told hey
listen hector just kind of back off a
little bit more this is enough you've
come enough you don't need to say
anything anymore just stay quiet move on
with your life go about your business
were you getting anybody that was
messaging you to
not pursue it anymore and just kind of
back off
and not originally they wanted me to go
after and convict
the people that were involved in killing
not only camarena they they killed uh
four jojoba witnesses the same cartel
which of course was
a cartel they had also killed two
americans at a
restaurant owned by rafael quintero john
walker and alberto rodolette
and i personally wanted to go after
these guys
because you know they they
they not only just killed the americans
they the women were raped
viciously in front of the husbands the
jehovah witnesses
women were the two americans that were
killed
at the restaurant that i mentioned john
walker
and albert radolette not only were they
just killed they were dismembered i mean
they were decapitated they were all cut
up
and before they were actually killed
they bone tingled them to investigate
them
these are very very vicious uh criminals
and i i wanted to exert some revenge
especially against uh against the
the the perpetrators that raped the
women
you know they raped them and then after
that they ran a rope between their legs
torturing them
what vicious animals so i wanted to go
after them
and when and unfortunately one of those
guys
one of those suspects that was involved
in raping the jehovah witnesses
is about to be released here in a couple
of weeks jose bernabe
ramirez so i i i
i wanted vengeance and i wanted to
arrest these guys
did you ever get your vengeance i got
some vengeance
i mean i got in shootout with him and i
i took some
some of their lives they also almost
shut up some of my guys
and they killed my friend camarena but
hey it was a war
it was war and uh we were going at it at
each other
so so going back at it when you look at
these four uh
major cartels you have the guadalajara
cartel which is by the name you just
mentioned rafael caro quintero
who is in a lot of songs you know a lot
of corrido you know a lot of songs that
they
name him and they uh uh glorify him then
you have the tijuana cartel with
an edina ariano felix then you have the
sinaloa cartel which is el chapo and you
have the juarez cartel which is rafaela
aguilar
uh guardo i believe which one of those
four is known as the most
vicious feared cartel
right now i would say is sinaloa cartel
the sinaloa cartel is in war
with the uh chapitos which is the um
chapel guzman's sons they were involved
with each other right now
the sinaloa cartel is very much
protected right now by the current
administration
the chapitos and the melaka which is
another
uh drug cartel are being supported by
the uh
pri guys uh the guys that formerly um
basically had the presidency under
enrique pena nieto
see in mexico the cartels
are powerful and do things with impunity
because they have government protections
if they were not protected by the
government or had not been protected by
the government
back in 1985 they wouldn't have dared
picked up camarena
but because they had the dfs working
with him they had the mexican federal
release
police working with him they had they
had the jalisco state police with him
this is what gave them the power and to
this day
they have that kind of support
by the corrupt inept
mexican government at that time so you
say today sinaloa cartel who was the
strongest at that time was it
guadalajara by
rafa well back back uh at the time that
was picked up in 85 it was the
guadalajara cartel and they by the way
they were the only cartel at the time
we dismantled that cartel by arresting
their their
their uh cafe
we arrested all those guys so after
after we destroyed the guadalajara
cartel
the other little car cartel started
springing up
felix gallardo when we arrested him gave
his
part of uh black cartel to felix ariano
brothers
out of tijuana the felix are young
brothers ramon and
and jorge and those guys at chapel
guzman and widow palma they formed their
own cartel
and of course they broke off with
the cinema i mean what had a cartel
started their own cartel
and then they started being supplied
they're cocaine by the kali cartel
now the guadalajara cartel had been
receiving their cocaine
from uh pablo vallam out of the medellin
cartel
got it got it so when you're saying
support you're saying the mexican
government is supporting
el chapo's son or uh several of these
cartels they have the backing of the
government
totally okay so so when when rafael caro
quintero went to jail i think i don't
know the exact time he did 26 years but
he went and he did some time
and at the time did you ever get a
chance to meet him and be face to face
with him or no you never had a chance to
meet rafael
no i never met him personally
i was very much involved in his arrest
or even though i was i wasn't there
so so based on him how was he at that
time because
you know he was very charming very
charismatic very you know
almost kids grew up looking up to this
guy with the energy that he had
how powerful was he at that time in the
middle in the mid 80s
okay before he was 30 years old he was
not a millionaire
he was already a billionaire and i know
because i found his money
here is a guy 28 29 years old
has access to jets he bought his own
deal jet in tucson arizona
he was very powerful very very powerful
but he was very very uneducated and not
not very smart
okay i'll say that about him he wasn't
very smart but he was feared he was
absolutely he was he was feared uh at
one time
uh he was uh given as a gift a a real
a real nice um uh i heard 38
caliber pistol and to try it out he just
shot somebody in a bar just to try it
out kill the person
that's how vicious he was got it
and and when you think about when the
story comes out with kiki you hear two
different names
both of them are co-founders of the gua
of the guadalajara cartel
whether it's miguel gallardo or it's
rafa
cara quintero so who is the person that
actually killed
kiki well they were all involved
they were all there they all wanted to
hear what kiki had to say
they all participated in slapping him
kicking him spitting on him pulling his
hair
that that type of situation they burnt
him uh
with cigarettes and they also would open
up ak-47 cartridges
pour the powder over his chest and light
him up and he was burnt bad
they all participated in
it wasn't i guess one of them they
didn't go into the room where he was
being held
they didn't at least slap him everybody
was trying to act more macho
and kicking and slapping a poor man that
was hog-tied
i mean these are real animals
well i want to show you video and i'm
curious to get your reaction on this
when you see this video
of rafa from back in the days what do
you think about when you see this video
i'm curious to get your reaction
foreign
is
[Music]
foreign
what do you think about when you see him
speaking in that video
when i think about it it upsets me he's
uh
i know he's living in a golden cage he
has permitted
taking out to have dinners at
restaurants while he's in custody
he's allowed to carry a gun in his cell
he uh basically living
a very nice life while incarcerated and
he knows that sooner or later he'll be
able to buy himself out
uh as you see he's he's he seems very
happy he doesn't seem like he's being
punished at all now you know
the the challenge is a lot of people uh
say he still has money but you've seen
the interview he did where he said i
don't have any money you know i'm broke
people are giving me food
you know i'm i'm struggling with life
right now etc etc
based on you having more information
than the rest of us
do you think he still has a lot of the
money he had before into power or do you
think he doesn't have anywhere close to
the power he had back in the 80s
i know he has a lot of money in panama
if you recall it was a panama papers
investigation that came out about two
years ago
he has millions of money
of dollars in panamanian accounts
when i investigated him back in 85
we i my team the liana team
found almost a billion dollars that he
had
at a luxembourg bank uh in germany
now we seized that money and we
later found out that that money also
went back then
to ali north in support of the congress
that billion dollars back then and this
is a billion dollars back in the 80s
back in in 1985 well 89 actually when we
found it so
they they show that there's a 20 million
dollar reward on him is there still a
reward or was that back in the days
i see the number 20 million dollars all
over the place he is
uh the the most wanted agent
by the fbi and there is a 20 million
dollar reward
for anybody that will turn him in but
nobody is going to turn him in because
he is now jeffrey de jeffers of the
cabor cartel
he has president he said recently uh
formed his own cartel
a la camolca sonora and in the last
three or four months he has killed over
20 people he himself back in the game
so he's back in the game yes
and is that proven is that something
that people know yes it's
known what's what's his level of papers
in mexico
the shootouts are basically there's been
a lot of killings and uh
he is a war also with the chabuzman
organization with the
chapitos so they're together they're
they're unite they're running together
no they're they're warring with each
other they hate each other they're
warring with each other okay got it they
can't stand each other
who's more used but sinaloa is more
powerful than they are today
i believe that the the the strongest
more prolific right now cartel in mexico
is the cinema cartel
which is being run by el mayo sambada
got it um when you think about the
corridos when you listen to the songs do
you listen to any corridors yourself or
no
yes i do okay so i have a lot of friends
who are from
michoacan or jalisco or sakatecas or
oaxaca or any of these places
and i'll sit in the car and they'll play
some corridos and the music
i'm middle eastern i can't help but my
hips just start moving itself it's like
automatic you know because the music
goes
but whether it's the old school chalino
sanchez or the new school
tercer elemento how do you feel when you
hear these songs and they're you know
they're building up rapha they're
they're
portraying them as a hero how do you see
that when you see the music
it upsets me a lot especially the one
where it's settled
i didn't kill camarena when when we know
he was very much involved
as a matter of fact uh when kiki was
basically in agony
fonseca who was ahead of the heavens
ordered uh him basically taken to a
hospital
that's when they brought in dr machine
kiki was not supposed to be killed
and so fonseca was very upset
that was upset that that that kiki had
been
tortured so severely and uh he
ordered my shine to go ahead and take
him to the hospital and carol quintero
intervened and he said nope
he's not going to no hospital he's a dea
agent we cannot
you know take that chance of taking him
to a hospital
ponzico says but he's going to die he
says i don't give a [ __ ] let him die
and forsake him was so mad that he
slapped
carol quintero so hard in the face that
he almost knocked him down
as a matter of fact my witnesses which
were some of the pistolers
they all went for their guns and of
course carol quiters gunman also went
for their guns
and according to what they tell me they
would have outgunned carol quintero's
guys because there was more of them
for fonseca than carlos carol had for
taking him
but carol quintero is a
is a dummy because can you imagine had
they not killed
marina how big they would be now
how big would they have been oh my god
they would basically be controlling the
whole government of mexico
as it was i mean they they entertained
presidents
uh they they would they would make trips
to los pinos which is mexico's white
house i have two witnesses that went
uh with foseka to meet with
president-elect madrid a couple of
occasions
at rospinos this is uh the kind of
influence they already had
so you know you're you said earlier that
the the cartel is stronger today than
before
why why do you say that why do you say
the cartel is stronger today than before
because we have access to better
technology
there is better ways to do surveillance
why do you think the cartel is stronger
today than before
because in the old days when um
ernesto fonte carrillo was was running
the cartels
he had very strict rules there was no
intervention
allowed with the regular citizens of
mexico
if they if they killed anybody that was
not part of
other cartel network without a reason
that was
death to those guys in other words he
had a federation he would have meetings
with him and say
okay what's going on i'm not going to
allow any
any disorder i'm not going to allow any
violence
and no they're you're not going to
kidnap people you're not going to extort
money from people
that was not allowed by fonseca he had
strict
control and rules the cartels now
they extort from the citizens they
pick up girls and rape them uh they're
out of control
look at what they just did last year to
the lebron family the the
mormons that were massacred november the
5th of 2019
that were traveling to mexico uh to a
wedding
it was there was no there was no grown
men in that group there was 13
women and children and the cartel were
mad at the lebron
because they had not been paid
extortion monies every month they had
refused to and this
was done to basically and still fearing
them
and bring them into line so that they
could be extorted
there were so vicious that after
shooting the
nine women and children there was three
babies left in baby chairs
and they lit fire into the cars and
burned those babies to death
and that would never have happened
during the uh
guadalajara cartel days the old man
would have not permitted that
luciano of the italian mob is that kind
of a way of putting it where he was a
chairman he kind of
led all the families together absolutely
he was the heavy the heaviest
he ruled with an iron fist he issued the
different
plazas or areas where everybody was
going to be working
he had the arellanos in tijuana he had
juan garcia abrego in texas he doled out
the different areas
and everybody was working under his
command
everybody was working underneath him it
wasn't until after like i said
we destroyed the cartel that
all these little cartels are springing
springing up all over the place
and they started warring with each other
and that's why it's
worse now than it ever was back in 1985.
you think it all will settle down do you
think it'll ever calm down
and what does we mean we as united
states or we as the mexican government
as a matter of fact president trump
offered to send seals
army rangers into mexico to deal with
the cartels once for all
after the lebron murders there in sonora
and uh nobel road would have nothing to
do with it
who wouldn't have nothing to do with it
a president of mexico he said
that he was not he didn't want a war
with the cartels
that he was going to solve the drug
problem
with brussels not bad lassos with hogs
not bullets he really said that he said
that
he said that to president trump yes
he's going to solve it with hugs
not weapons yes without bullets ballast
means bullets ballassos means bullets
wow i mean it's tough to uh
when somebody's using bullets and you
want to go hug them
you're probably enough having a bullet
in your back when you do that you know
it's a different kind of a war you're
fighting so
are you saying um are you saying so you
said the only way it will happen is if
we help them america
so maybe it's not america maybe it's a
different kind of a leader that mexico
needs to have that's willing to
cooperate with america so what is the
chances of mexico having a president
that's willing to cooperate with u.s
you know it's hard because drugs
you know they corrupt people i mean look
at the money that pena nieto got for
instance from
uh el chapo guzman it came out during
the trial
was exposed there was plenty of
testimony that
he was given 250 million dollars
and that wasn't enough for pena nieto he
wanted more money
and let me tell you another thing who do
you think funds are campaigns for these
guys that that come in like are you
president
if the cartels funded he tried to
uh win the presidency before and it
wasn't until he partnered up with
the biggest narco-political in mexico uh
manuel barde diaz
he brokered the the the the
the arrangement between the cartels and
uh lopez political party and that is
really why the reason he's a president
he's been holding to these guys i
specifically remember that article that
came out on how much money was being uh
uh paid to uh win uh
power over the political power by the
cartel i remember that article i don't
know if it was a wall street journal
article but i remember vividly
reading uh that article but uh so so
when you when you see
trump building the wall uh how do you
view that you're somebody that's been on
both sides you have somebody you're
somebody that's seen the good the bad
the ugly the ugliest
of what happens out there what do you
think about the wall being built is it
going to do anything to protect the
southern border
we need the wall it's not
just basically impeding rocks from
coming in
what about our enemies what about the
taliban and
and all of the enemies that we have in
the world they can come in
through a porous mortar also it's not
just drugs
we believe it or not we need that wall
for our national security just just not
to have a wall and have people come in
and out
we're going to get terrorists in here
we're going to get we're going to be
inundated with drugs and we need that
wall
did you see the last debate that took
place where the topic of coyotes came
out
yes i did what are your thoughts when
that conversation came
came back and forth about what happens
when these coyotes are bringing the
you know kids over what what does that
look like for some that have no clue
what that looks like can you
educate some of the folks that don't
know what the business model of coyotes
is
coyotes are criminals like any other
criminal
they do not only smuggling humans they
also smuggle in drugs
and those modeling terrorists they're
there to make
a buck they are criminals they actually
uh pay people to lend their women and
children
to pose as children coming in with
criminals
let's say that a drug organization wants
to bring in
uh let's say an assassin what they'll do
is they'll go to a coyote the coyote
will pay
a family to lend a small child to the
assassin
so that he can bring come in and say
i'm here with my daughter i'm here with
my child and
he'll they'll probably let him in okay
so coyotes are criminals
like any any other criminal they're
there to make any
illegal illegal dollar and they'll do
anything
to include bringing in drugs
to include uh providing
uh blood traffickers with children so
that they could
basically clean they're their kids
they're into all of this criminality
how do you know this yourself you know
this because you're you've seen it you
witnessed it or you hear about it from
your peers
i i investigated it even back then it
was happening
back in the back in 85 this is nothing
new
they've used this tactics and techniques
since way back
and you think the wall is going to help
that minimize it
absolutely i think it'll it'll it'll
it'll help it's not going to stop it
they're always going to figure a way to
bring in drugs and
basically bring in uh humans do the
human trafficking they're just going to
find another way to do it
they'll either fly them in or bring them
in by boat or
dig more tunnels as we've seen they will
always figure out a way to get
uh their drugs in so so
last thought on this topic before we
move on so based on what you're saying
is
you you don't see this cartel model
slowing down for
decades and decades and decades
that is correct as as long as there's a
demand for drugs
there will be those that are going to
provide him
the cartels it's not going to stop in
mexico
until we go in and clean it up and i
don't even know if
this country really wants to clean it up
this has been going on for years
our cia everybody knows inundated our
country with
with cocaine our cia was the biggest
cocaine cartel in the in the late 80s
and into the 90s
they created a generation of crack
addicts in the inner cities
look at all the violence that came
behind all of that when you had the
bloods and the crips killing
each other over drug turfs look at all
the
please look at all the overdoses look at
all the families that were affected
by the cia inundating
our inner cities with cocaine
how do you think i felt as a dea agent
when i was told do i risk that
that person anybody white black that
doesn't matter go arrest him he's he's
got 10 ounces
of cocaine for sale i would go arrest
him take him to trial he would get 15 20
years in prison
then we would go and stop a plane that
had 20 tons of cocaine
and it was a cia plane with a ca
operative and we were told
oh don't do nothing to him that's a cia
operation leave it alone
we knew they were inundated our cities
was with cocaine i knew it
i was involved in the blonde raisin in
in in the
in the 80s blonde
official who was inundating
south central with with cocaine he was
the one that was uh
supplying highway ricky ross with
hundreds of kilos of cocaine
yeah we've had rick ross here as well
and we've had conversation with him too
uh before here let me ask you which one
of the former presidents of mexico was
close to being able to go against
the cartel and he wasn't afraid of it
for instance vicente fox or
was there ever a mexican president that
there was a slight chance of things
changing in mexico
or no any president that gets in there
pretty much bought out
not in my time when i was with dea
we always information that the
presidents were
protecting the drug lords and we're
getting money
and also drugs for their personal use
from
the drug lords got it okay
uh last question here before we wrap up
is
uh have you seen the show narcos both
colombia and now mexico
yes i have how accurate is it from
somebody that's been in that world
from your eyes it's all i would say
it's like uh 90 creative writing most of
it is not true
i don't like show because they glamorize
the drug lords in the last episode
they show forget his name the actor that
was playing
gallardo's role inviting kiki to a
dinner it is being held they cater food
for kiki as he's being held
and he's asking keiki to please
cooperate
um yeah it was jake waldo the actor that
was playing that part
i wanted to vomit you know why do they
do this
what do they want to glamorize a stone
killer a sociopath which is what rayardo
was
what do they do that that's not true
kiki wasn't even
offered a glass of water please give me
a break
you can tell there's emotions there with
you i mean you you're someone that was
involved and it's
easily felt just listening to you here
uh from where you're at so you know i'll
give you the last thoughts here right
now
uh just to know that our audience
has seen a lot of different stories
they've sat here and watched steve
murphy and javier pena they've sat here
and listened to
sammy double gravano we've had a lot of
different mobs
we've had people that are political
we've had presidents on we've had
billionaires on what are your final
thoughts you want to say to the viewer
on the relationship between us the
borders mexico southern borders cartel
what are some final thoughts you want to
leave the viewer with
what i want to leave the viewer with is
this
i cannot believe that to this day there
are
identified suspects in the murderer
camarena
in our country that have not been
indicted and arrested i tried to arrest
these folks
and i was told to back off and i think
it is
time that the american public know
that our government has not protected
them from these cartels
our government itself was involved
in inundating our country with
drugs they did not care
of who died of overdoses they did not
care about the bloodshed that their
drugs were causing in our inner cities
all they cared about was funding
a capricious war that had not been
authorized
by the us government corruption
continues
greatly in mexico but there's also a lot
of corruption here
i was hoping that with my documentary
the last narc
that it would basically get the
attention of people and say what are we
doing here
why are these people that were involved
in in kiki's murder
like the cia operative and an american
corrupt agent that
set up kiki why have they not been
arrested
and you know put to justice i want
i want to invite people to read it's all
here in my book
you know the last narc i encourage you
to read and and i have a lot of
information that i have not
basically talked about here in this
program that they need to know
they need to know them in serious ways
and the corrupt ways
that our intelligence agencies involve
themselves
with these rock cartels not just back
then
i believe they're still doing it to this
day the
cia funds all their operations with drug
monies
till today wow so here's what we're
going to do we're going to put the link
to your book below we're going to put
the link to your uh
uh serious below as well then last narc
on amazon go watch it before there's a
conflict and they take it down as well
as
i believe you're starting a youtube and
a podcast called cartel madness we'll
put the link below for that as well
uh having said that hector thank you so
much for taking the time
for sharing your story on valuetainment
thank you it's been a pleasure different
kind of a perspective right coming from
a dea agent when he tells you what's
really going on mexico with the cartel
and uh what happened in the 80s versus
trillium by the way if you enjoyed this
interview
i also did another interview with steve
murphy and javier pena who were the two
dea agents
that went up against pablo escort
escobar if you've never seen that
click over here to title the videos who
killed pablo escobar
uh it's a riveting story if you've never
seen it before and if you're not
subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
[Music]
you